when it comes to popularity versus
screen time there may be no bigger
winner than Boba Fett for decades fans
have been fervently buying action
figures comics and novels featuring the
world's favorite Bounty Hunter sorry dog
people love fat even though he has about
four lines of dialogue in the entire
original trilogy before being knocked
into a giant Pit by a blind guy
because of his popularity and his
limited screen time it would be easy to
think that Boba Fett doesn't have any
hidden secrets however the truth is that
there's still plenty you probably don't
know about this mysterious character
from a galaxy far far away his first
real appearance most people know that
Boba Fett first appeared on the big
screen in The Empire Strikes Back no
matter what George Lucas did to the
special edition of A New Hope later on
the real Savvy fan may even be able to
tell you fed's first appearance on any
screen was drawing 1978 Star Wars
holiday special maybe I can help you I
am Boba Fett but neither of those are
actually the first time the public got
to see Boba Fett his first public
appearance was a few weeks earlier on
September 24 1978 at the San Anselmo
County Fair San Anselmo was the home of
Luca's film at the time and George Lucas
thoughts that taking part in the local
parade was a great idea while Fett
didn't engage in any pie eating contests
or hog calling assistant film Direct
Dwayne Dunham donned the sweaty costume
and signed autographs even though no one
actually knew who Boba Fett was yet all
white even before Boba Fett took his
unusual place in a local parade and a
terrible holiday special he'd been going
through some changes concept artist
Ralph McQueary had a ton of different
designs for Boba that he was testing out
ultimately settling on the Mandalorian
armor fans know and love today the
original suit was completely fabricated
and Screen tested except it was
completely Stormtrooper white sure he
still had a cool jet pack and a Sinister
visor but he was basically a bleached
out version of the green and red guy of
today why those original Armor Designs
were originally planned to be old
stormtrooper armor from an old regiment
which would have made him look like a
medieval Knight marching into war with
modern soldiers but you know in space as
plans for the film shifted and the lore
began to grow the armor became
Mandalorian fed took a smaller role and
he finally got some much needed color
the big bad
according to an interview with
lucasfilm's first fan relations officer
Chris Miller vet was originally going to
play a much larger role in the trilogy
which is why he had such a prominent
role in the holiday special at one point
he was even going to Eclipse Darth Vader
as the trilogy's biggest bad guy
Star Wars from a dozen films down to
three compacted his entire second
Trilogy concept into Return of the Jedi
and threw Fett into a belching desert
cloaca
taking action when Star Wars has an
action figure controversy and they
happen surprisingly often it usually
revolves around Leia's gold bikini or
too few Rave figures on the shelves but
the original Star Wars action figure
controversy stemmed from none other than
Boba Fett
[Music]
let's recap fed's first appearance was
at a County Fair his second appearance
was in the holiday special his third
appearance prior to the May 1980 release
of Empire Strikes Back was on the back
of Action Figure packaging as a mail
away figure when he still didn't have a
backstory just one problem the fat
figure was portrayed with a rocket
firing backpack Star Wars fans who were
basically the original turbo nerds were
pretty upset at not receiving the
action-packed fair today were promised
Kenna had produced some prototypes of
the full figure which have since become
the Holy Grail of Star Wars collectibles
but they were never released to the
public due to safety concerns after a
child choked on a missile from a
Battlestar Galactica toy Hasbro bought
Kenner in 2010 and finally made things
right when they released an actual
rocket firing Boba Fett as a male away
in their vintage collection
finally adult nerds everywhere got their
fondest wish death by action figure if
they can just figure it out without
killing each other just push push the
button push I'm pushing
good God
that's many Origins attack of the Clones
made it absolutely clear that Boba Fett
is the unaltered clone of legendary
Bounty Hunter Jango Fett the prototype
for all of the Galaxy's clone troopers
unlike his helmeted clone Bros Boba is
raised personally by Django and
eventually takes his own place in the
Galaxy as a bounty hunter but even
before attack of the Clones the Star
Wars expanded universe had developed a
rich backstory for just about every
weirdo in every scene of Star Wars no
matter how irrelevant even ice cream
maker guy fun fact his name is willro
Hood he's a rebel hero he has his own
action figure he has a legion of fans
and in terms of screen time versus fan
fervor he just might beat out Boba Fett
anyway according to tales of the bounty
hunters a novel released in 1996 Boba
Fett's real name was Jaster Mariel and
he's essentially an ex-cop from the
world known as Concord Dawn who's exiled
from the planet for killing his corrupt
Superior eventually he's taken in by the
the mandalorians and becomes Boba Fett
after attack of the Clones however
Jaster was Rewritten to be a completely
separate character from Fett in the
comic series Jango Fett Open Seasons
Jaster Maria was the leader of Mandalore
and the guy who took a young Django Fett
under his wing after Django's parents
were murdered occasionally though both
Boba and Django would use jaster's name
as their own kinda like an Intergalactic
Rusty Shackleford he survived a fight
with Vader the original trilogy implies
that Boba Fett and Darth Vader have a
pretty okay relationship but readers of
Star Wars comics over the years have
witnessed a rather Unforgettable side to
Vader and fed trying to All Out murder
each other sure they're mostly
non-canonical now but that doesn't mean
it's not fun to see first there's a
fight in Star Wars Tales number 11 where
Fete actually holds his own against
Vader in a lightsaber battle in a
Cantina Bader and Fett faced off once
again in Boba Fett enemy of the Empire
number four where the stakes were a bit
higher in truly bizarre Comics fashion
the two fight fight over the severed but
still talkative head of a
fortune-telling alien queen Boba Fett
has hired to retrieve the head in a box
but Vader wants it as a tool for his
eventual overthrow of Emperor Palpatine
the two come to blows with Vader
deflecting Blaster bolts and cutting fed
getaway speeder in half until he stops
screwing around and force chokes fat who
kicks the head off a cliff and jet packs
to safety while Vader uses the force to
retrieve it with the two only ended up
having a pleasant work relationship
later on because a decapitated Queen
heads says they will and Vader is pretty
superstitious but they probably also
bonded over how difficult it is to go to
the bathroom while wearing armor eggs is
enough you'd think that Darth Vader
would have taken the record for the most
actors portraying the same character on
the big screen between actors last
second stand-ins and voice actors not to
mention stuntmen but Boba Fett really
wins that award since for the most part
whoever fit into the armor got to play
him Jeremy Bullock played fet through
most of the characters appearances in
the original trilogy with the exception
of two days when he missed filming and
the actor who played the rebel Pilot's
Dak John Morton filled in throughout the
original trilogy Jason wingreen provided
his voice for the special editions he
was dubbed by Tamora Morrison the actor
who played Jango Fett and when George
Lucas needed more fat footage for his
special editions he decided to just use
three different industrial Light and
Magic employees who happen to fit into
the outfit finally for the prequels
young Boba was played by Daniel Logan
who also provided the voice for Boba
Fett in the Clone Wars cartoon and we're
not even counting video games radio
dramas or Star Tours King of the
mandalorians though it's been wiped out
by Star Wars massive continuity overhaul
Boba Fett was once the leader of his
entire planet of Mandalore just like his
father was before him what's the name of
the leader of all of Mandalore the fifth
planet in the Mandalore system quite
simply Mandalore that word probably
works for everything it's like Aloha
Shalom Smurf or squanch squanchy party
bro squatchy is there a good place for
me to squat around here watch you you
can Squatch wherever you want man the
actual history of the Mandalorian seems
to shift around a lot but in the 2008
Star Wars novel Legacy of the force
Revelation that's reluctant rise to
power is spelled out clearly he's hired
to kill the existing Mandalore leader
fencheiser who ends up saving fed's life
but scheissa is critically injured in
the process as a result fetus bounds to
honor his last request that Fett himself
become the new Mandalore of Mandalore as
such fetz had the mandalorians fight
back against the alien yujang vong
invader in the novella Boba Fett a
practical man and helped restore
Mandalore after the war make Mandalore
great again right
fed's family another thing lost to
Disney's revised continuity was fed's
family which he started 16 years before
a new hope it's weird to think of fat as
a doting Dad but he and his Bounty
Hunter wife Sint has fell settled down
and had a daughter named aylin when Fett
was only 19. unfortunately for everyone
Cintas is assaulted by boba's boss who
Boba then kills sending him spiraling
into Exile and divorce since as ends up
frozen in carbonite for four decades and
their daughter goes on a misguided quest
to kill Boba Fett herself not only that
but aylin trains her own daughter
murdered her to follow in her footsteps
and you thought your family was messed
up all of that and Boba Fett still found
time to train the expanded universe
Daughter of Han and Leia Jaina Solo with
the help of vet and his granddaughter
murder gev jaina is able to kill her
evil brother Jason and restore peace to
the Galaxy so no matter what reality
you're following Han and Leia have one
really messed up evil kid this
Skywalkers are bad news thanks for
watching click the Looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too
[Music]